(soft music)
- [Narrator] In the cold
white north of Minnesota
there's a place that will get you warm
after a long day on the ice.
You can do some fishing.
Or have a tasty beverage.
(cheering)
And it's something of a dream for Josie.
- I've always wanted to
own a neighborhood bar.
And we finally do, mine is
just sitting on a frozen lake.
Ice fishing is a way of
life around here for people.
It gets so cold, below
zero temps quite often
which allows us to
drive and put houses out
and drill holes in the lake and fish.
- [Narrator] When it gets cold
enough in the early winter,
Josie's husband goes out and tests the ice
to make sure it's thick enough.
If it is, they can put the bar together
and the the ice hole can open.
The ice here is so thick
that this bar sits on top of it.
To come to our bar on the lake,
you just drive your car
out on the ice and park
we don't have a parking lot
you just park wherever you want,
walk in and have a beer.
People like to fish and drink beer
and from our bar here, you can
do that all at the same time.
The local favorite drink
is called the minnow shot.
People will actually take a live minnow
which is fishing bait,
and put it into their shot and drink it.
- Oh boy.
- Oh yeah.
- He wiggled a little bit.
- Yeah.
- [Narrator] As delicious as
that seafood beverage sounds
people come just because
the fact that the bar exists
is pretty amazing.
- People's reactions to
this bar are from crazy
to they don't understand it
to it's the coolest thing ever.
They come from all over
the world to see it.
It's very seasonal, we're
only opened 20 days.
If you're ever near Lake Lida,
drive out on the ice,
park, come into the bar
and grab a pole.